[Music]
[Music]
so often when people think about
improving their speed and power and
explosiveness they'll be looking at
quite surface-level things in order to
improve so they will look at things like
exercises or strengthening techniques to
work on the individual muscles of the
body
and often people messaged me about this
and asked me things like how do I you
know get my hands faster how are the
only tips to become more explosive and
stuff like that and I often tell them
the same thing which is like before any
of that stuff before you even start to
think about that stuff ensure that your
technique is nice and efficient and
you're constantly refining it as you go
forward because if you think about it
adding a load of extra strength and
power upon to a poor technique is
essentially like building a house upon
shaky foundations and you don't add all
that stuff on without knowing the
underlying changes that need to be made
to maximize the techniques effectiveness
going forwards one of the most
overlooked things is the energy transfer
throughout the body to generate power as
well as maintain that throughout combos
that you're throwing by riding that
momentum if you will in kinetic linking
is pretty much involved in any sport
that involves power and speed but
obviously we're going to be looking at
it in terms of striking for martial arts
so we've got two modalities to speak
about here one is a basic overview and
the other is more specifically to
chaining strikes together while
maintaining power momentum so most
sports start from the ground up within
the placement of the FIH we're gonna be
talking about a general overview of how
power is generated first from the legs
and then travels throughout the body but
then looking more in detail into
specifically continuing that momentum
through our combos that you throw in and
this is where technique and economy of
motion comes into play and using one
strike to build on to the next and so on
first off we need to talk about order of
recruitment which is basically the order
at which the specific muscles of the
body are called upon and then build upon
each other like links in a chain and
compound to the final strike so looking
at boxing specifically then the force
originates within the feet the rear foot
drives backwards then the energy travels
up the leg twists through the hips then
goes to the back chest and shoulders and
then finally down the arm to the strike
MultiPlan that momentum through all the
leverage of the previous parts
so this graphic is a visual
representation of how this works with
all the different body parts kind of
building upon each other
and compound it into that final impact
point so I found this really interesting
article from sweet science of fighting
and it talks about one of the earliest
studies that looked at contributors to
punching forces in different levels of
box's experience intermediate and novice
they identified three different
components to an effective punch
experienced boxers had greater
contributions from the legs compared to
other levels of boxes and compared to
the arm and trunk contributions they
also showed less involvement of the arm
musculature compared to other levels of
boxes and somebody is a really clear
example of this is the boxer Deontay
Wilder and why he'd managed to kind of
score such consistent knockout numbers
in his career thus far but that was only
until he faced Tyson Fury recently would
obviously researched wireless technique
understood that he needed all that time
distance and the base of his feet in
order to throw his devastating punches
and so Fury's tactic was to push Wilder
onto the back foot and kind of cut off
insert his power source and his main
weapons and obviously Wilder was not
able to strike anywhere near how he did
in his previous matches very
[Applause]
and fury also purposely weighed in far
heavier than their first match to
further maximize his hugely dominating
forwards momentum so what we're
essentially looking at here is a perfect
flow of energy and momentum throughout
the different body parts to the final
point of the strike which kind of
explains why somebody who's small who's
trained to strike effectively can out
punch somebody who's much bigger and
much heavier who isn't trained because
obviously they don't know the correct
technique however size does matter in
terms of trained athletes because if a
big person and the small person are both
trained to strike effectively then
naturally the bigger man is gonna be
able to hit harder just because he's got
much more weight behind his strikes
which is why the heavyweights are
generally considered to be the cream of
the crop in terms of being the baddest
men on the planet so that was a general
overview of kinetic linking when it
comes to punching for a single strike
but now we're going to talk about it
more in terms of training different
moves together and how to transfer the
energy between all those techniques
without wasting it at different points
what's really important to work upon
here again I know it kind of sounds a
bit like a broken record I can't stress
enough how important it is to have a
really refined and clean technique
moving forwards because the more clean a
person's technique then the more kind of
fluidly they're going to be able to move
and the more they're gonna be able to
easily flow those moves together and not
waste energy in between and I'll refer
to this as economy of motion of the
technique which is essentially the
ongoing process of refining a technique
to remove unnecessary movement to make
it as direct simple and efficient as
possible and it's this constant
refinement that makes the seasoned
exponent of any endeavor perform
effortlessly in a way that seems
impossible for a beginner to comprehend
and I won't go too much into economy of
motion in this video but this principle
is one of the biggest secrets to
striking speed and is more important
than muscular strength during one of our
training sessions together Adam made the
observation that my movements were far
more economical and his which he
explained in a previous video that he
felt tired very quickly during one of
our sessions and obviously there's other
things like adrenaline at play here and
just generally being used to the type of
training but if you see in these clips
here Adams not using his legs enough
making his body continue to move forward
and not discharge sufficient energy into
each strike before moving on to the next
one so as mentioned before the tendency
is when thinking about speed is to try
to rush through all the strikes and kind
of end up subconsciously cut
sure which actually has a paradoxical
effect so by doing that people kind of
think they're moving through the strikes
quicker but what actually makes you move
through them quicker is setting up the
next one so there's less movement to do
between each one if that makes sense now
this isn't a completely ultimate thing
meaning that you have one or the other
there's always going to be a bit of a
sacrifice with whatever you kind of
going for so if you want to go for a big
power light Wilder you're obviously
going to need more time as well as
potentially full enough balance after
strike in however if you just go in for
speed then you're obviously going to
sacrifice some power and you want to
find a nice balance between the two
where you're able to strike quickly and
explosively but also hit powerfully and
this is what often it looks like when
you see somebody who's really seasoned
somebody like a manny pacquiao that
looks like he's moving very quickly or
still hitting very hard as well and this
is gonna be different for everybody's
different body types you know taking
into account things like limb length
musculature height weight and everything
else in between so in order to elaborate
the example of the sacrifice let's talk
about throwing something like a 1-2-3 or
jab cross hook you don't know extend the
cross as much as you would if you were
finishing on that strike because that's
gonna slow you down and make you
mechanical but at the same time you
don't want to rush through every strike
because then they're all going to be
compromised even in a shorter cross
position leading to a hook my shoulder
if you can see here is still forward
delivering a powerful strike and this is
different for everyone's bodies and limb
weights
[Music]
now this is really getting quite deeply
technical but you often see people when
they will be shadowboxing for instance
they have some really nice long extended
punches well then when it comes to
hitting something hard like some pads or
a heavy bag the technique changes
because they're not used to the impact
of it obviously this is the one mid
combo and this is one at the end of the
combo you can see by the difference in
the extension of the arm however my
shoulders are both in a quite similar
position and they're the angles a bit
different so it's a little bit difficult
to see however what you see with most
people is when they are closer to a
target like this picture on the left
they're obviously able to calculate that
distance change but what they will do is
they will make up for the distance using
the shoulders instead of the arms so
they will actually push this right
shoulder back and still extend the arm a
little bit like this which actually
really weakens the power so you see my
right shoulder still forward here
because I've twisted correctly at the
waist and transferred that energy into
my arm
whereas if you haven't done that then
the left shoulder will be more forward
and the arm will still be straight at
the closer target which is nowhere near
as powerful so I'm gonna go into another
screen recording in a moment and really
break down how I'm punching these pads
frame by frame now this was always a
super powerful tool I found in order to
break down technique and really kind of
tune into some of those sort of things
that people are doing when they're when
they're moving so hopefully it will be
useful to you guys as well if we take a
look at it now and the way I'm doing
this one is a little bit like Wilder
does where I'm actually pushing forwards
off it so I'm not just doing it
statically if you see I kind of shooting
from a leg and when you do this and we
just move this a moment when you do this
when I'm push this leg forward here this
actually creates a little bit even more
power so I'm pushing off this back leg
kind of like a fencing stance and
pushing in with that jab to start with
now when I do strike with the job if you
see my body is really really turned
aside with tea and nuts so I can
maximize the power from this back
shoulder often when we're doing just a
one two static it will be a little bit
more forward facing but if we watch that
clip of wild again very quickly you can
see pretty much how he's exactly on the
side as well it's like his whole body is
sidon and that's so all the power can
come from this back hand really really
drive through afterwards so if you see
again from here I push him
and then as this one comes it's got all
that distance to travel straight through
to that pad boom boom
cool so that's that one and we'll move
on to the next one now this one's a jab
cross hook hook or a 1 2 3 4 and this is
a really good way to see how one punch
can have sets up into the next one and
why it's really important to get your
body into the correct position before
moving on so that you don't cut yourself
short and weaken your explosive
potential moving forwards
so as we go again here we've got the jab
and the cross again so the cross is not
as extended this time but my right
shoulder is still in that important
forward position from here the left hand
is gonna come through and deliver this
hook come there and it's setting up for
this last powerful hook from here so if
you see here this arms getting really
stacked up and ready to go forwards for
the for the last hook and I'll lift it
up so I'm getting my shoulder right
through and pushing all that weight
forwards and when you kind of going
through all these again it's almost like
you're setting up for that big last
powerful shot while still making sure
that you're delivering enough power on
all the others as well as I mentioned
before you are gonna sacrifice some
level of extension in order to carry on
the techniques quicker as well as kind
of dropping your hands down I'm sure
there's gonna be some some people in the
comments that are saying things like oh
you drop your hands but if you watch
through this footage of Manny Pacquiao
again he does exactly the same when you
travel in this kind of speed you have to
drop your hands in order to sell the
next strike because if you don't it's
actually going to be slower moving
forward so that's why that kind of
happens and if you see it in full speed
it's hardly really gonna be much of a
problem
now this last one I want to talk about
is something that I saw Andy Ruiz jr. do
and he's an absolute savage powerhouse
so I was kind of watching how he was
hitting this this huge pad which I think
it's called a claw I'll just share that
clip now and I was watching how he was
moving and studying what he did in order
to generate that power and why I
observed was he actually punches through
the pad first before he throws his
second shot so PC me here I'll hit right
through it my with my right hand first
and then a left low body shot afterwards
but the important thing to talk about
here is how I actually punch right
through the bag so instead of just
stopping here and then going into this
this shot here by actually punching
right through can you see how now I'm
turning my body almost completely away
from the back and that's just gonna
generate a massive amount of power from
this backhand and this is actually still
really your clusters kind of like a lead
hook but because if you start from here
that's actually my lead lead hook
position and the backhand comes right
through enormous makes this like a real
hook so it's like switching completely
twisting at the waist and then my body's
turned a little bit more now but if you
were to see almost from this angle you
don't see like the right side of my face
here actually past the bag and then this
gives me all this leverage and talk to
swing right back through with that nice
left hook one
so hitting right through the bag and
turning your body away - in order to
generate power for that finishing shot
so thanks very much for watching this
video guys I hope you found it useful if
you have any questions about anything
just pop them down in the comments below
and I'm likely to start making more
content on my own YouTube channel as
well I know on the previous few videos
some people have asked where my channel
was and what I was doing and on the
Pioneer I kind of do a lot of like
general overview stuff and more
technical concepts but I'm thinking with
my channel I'm gonna do more kind of
in-depth tutorial base stuff and and
kind of step-by-step instructions for
different things so if you've got any
ideas for that as well please let me
know and I'll see you next time thank
you very much
[Music]
you